advent advent ein geldschein brennt
freunde der sonne herzlich willkommen zu
advent chemie heute mit dieser kerze und
money money als sachen andern ihr wisst
ja wie das ist ihr macht es euch
gemütlich er zündet eine kerze am jetzt
habt ihr das problem wie kriegt ihr die
kerze jetzt wieder aus ich habe heute
einen chemie live act für euch wie ihr
eine kerze austrägt und ihr denkt euch
jetzt weit
willst du uns erklären wie man eine
fucking kerze ausbläst leute tätig vor
ihr habt morgen einen tauch wettbewerbs
und müsst euren atem sparen
wie kriegt jetzt also diese kerze aus
ohne zu blasen
das geht ganz einfach in drei schritten
backpulver schritt nummer zwei essig und
schritt noch mal drei einfach das glas
an die kerze halten jetzt nicht glauben
das ganze noch mal für die kamera kehrte
nur gut dass jetzt aus aber die frage
ist wie kriegt jetzt wieder an
man könnte jetzt sagen mit diesem
fahrzeug aber warum einfach wenn es auch
geil geht wenn er eine kerze mit einem
feuerzeug anzünden möchte dabei aber
auch geld verbrennen möchte dann geht
das ganz einfach in neun schritten
schritt 1 schritt eins wir nehmen eine
eins zu eins mischung von ethanol und
wasser ich hatte jetzt zuhause zufällig
70-prozentige ethanol lösung nicht damit
ist im hartem wasser auf bis zu 1
gebracht habe die 2 wir nehmen einen
geldschein klar je größer der geldschein
desto geiler seite ich bin so mittel
teilnehmer zehn euro schritt 3 wir
tauchen diesen geldschein in die eins zu
eins ethanol wasser mischung oh ich hab
noch was vergessen
eine prise salz in den hinteren bänken
schritt 4 ich nehme meine
desinfektionslösung 70 prozent und macht
ein tropfen hier braucht besser wäre es
wenn man 100 prozentigen ethanol nehmen
würde habe ich leider nicht da schritt 5
wir holen uns eine schutzbrille wenn ihr
eure schutzbrille gerade nicht findet
könnt ihr natürlich auch eure
gesichtsmasken ganz klar
schritt 6 mio die geldscheine raus
schritt 7 ihr fast in mit einer zange an
schritt 8 geldscheinen anzünden ist
freunde da sondern ich musste kurz die
sonne ausschließen denn ich habe
festgestellt dass man nicht plane nicht
so gut sieht deswegen schritt 8 jetzt
noch mal im abgedunkelten raum macht es
vielleicht gerade einmal in diese kamera
damit ihr auch wirklich einmal schön
sieht wie der geldschein brennt
mist
nein nein
ein grund mehr für schritt nummer 9
nämlich nicht zu hause nachmachen räume
der sonne ich hoffe meine chemie live
hacks verändern euer leben nicht zumal
sie ja auch nicht zu hause ausprobieren
sollte aber wenn ihr wisst wie die ganze
magie von heute zu erklären ist vom
backpulver über den brennenden
geldscheinen bisschen zu diesem
gescheiterten experiment dann schreibt
es in die kommentare
jede korrekte chemische erklären kriegt
von mir persönlich ein taxi bleibt
sicher wir sehen uns in der endkampf